When our next guest got diagnosed with COVID-19,
he said the doctors and nurses not only saved his life,
but ultimately became his guardian angels.
Please take a look at his story.
Hi, my name's Kevin Devine.
I'm from Staten Island, New York.
I came down with COVID on March 28, 2020.
They were pumping me with all different drugs at the time
they thought were going to work and I was getting worse.
My oxygen level was down to almost six,
it's clear and simple, I was dying.
The doctor came in, he says, Kevin,
I got to put you on a ventilator.
I said to him, doc, I'm not going on a ventilator.
Everybody's gone on a ventilator has died or is dying.
So at the time I didn't know her name,
but her name is Janine,
young nurse I had two nights in a row.
She sits down next to me at the edge of the bed and goes,
you remind me of my dad.
And if my father was sitting in that bed right now,
I would tell my father to go on that ventilator.
The next thing I know,
I woke up 42 days later,
the nurse in the room jumped to the sky.
She goes, oh my God, you're alive!
'Cause I was just laying there like in a coma.
I had to learn how to walk, had to learn how to talk,
had to learn how to feed myself.
I lost 105 pounds.
There's no family.
My son, my daughter, my wife couldn't come.
So my nurses, they were my angels, they, you know,
gave me that, hey, you're gonna do it, you're gonna do it.
You got to do it.
And one nurse, I never got her name,
I'm so sorry I didn't,
came in the room one night, I was having a bad night.
I thank this nurse to this day,
she called my wife and said, hey, can you send a picture?
So they downloaded it and they printed it up
and the girl brought it in the room.
She goes, hey, maybe this will help.
And I stared at that picture day and night,
that was my will to get home,
my will to get strong, my will to keep fighting.
I really wish if she's out there and she sees this,
that I can one day get together with her
to tell her how that little gesture from her
meant so much to me.
(crowd cheers)
Hi Drew.
Hi Kevin.
How are you?
I am just, I'm so moved by your story.
Thank you, thank you for having me.
I'm so compelled by so many aspects of your story.
How does it feel for you,
retelling it now that there has been some time,
but putting yourself back in these moments?
It's tough Drew, like watching the video,
you can see it, my eyes started to well up.
Mine too, yeah absolutely.
That's unfair 'cause I pride myself
on being this big, tough guy.
And here I am, very first time I get on TV
and I got tears in my eyes.
So, kind of came off like, oh my God,
I gotta get my composure here.
And like I said in the story, the young nurse, Janine,
sat at the edge of the bed with me and told me,
go on the ventilator.
You gotta remember Drew,
I'm watching TV and everybody on the ventilators,
they're dying.
And I don't want to be,
I don't want to say this and sound rude or anything,
but there was a truck outside
filled with bodies of people who didn't make it.
That's how fast people were dying.
So now this young nurse, Janine, I love her.
I can say, she's, I'm gonna say this line
and I hope you understand what I'm saying.
She, those three girls are my Charlie's Angels,
they really were.
I love that so much.
(crowd applauds)
They mean more than my Charlie's Angels.
You know, and then when I made the decision,
I'm in the room and nurses on the right, nurses on the left,
they're putting all these things on me, getting me ready.
And this one nurse, Tina Marie, I grabbed her hand.
I says, listen, don't let me die.
Don't let me die.
And I looked at her and I says, if I die,
you please let them know I love them.
You let my wife and my kids know I love them.
I may not ever see them.
So, you're going through that
and while you're going through all that,
you know, next thing you know,
the doctor's wheeling you in.
And he's telling the guy,
the anesthesiologist start hitting, you know,
so the guy, the anesthesiologist looks at him and goes, why?
He goes, I'm crying.
The doctor even said, I'm crying.
This guy's, the emotion coming through him.
And like I said, then I woke up, like I said, 42 days later.
I opened my eyes and the nurse in the room had her tray
and she throws the tray in the air
'cause she's scared out of her mind.
She looks down at me, she goes, oh my God, he's alive.
And you know when somebody says that to you,
and you're looking around like, yeah I'm alive.
Of course I'm alive.
I'm not supposed to be dead, am I?
Should I, you know, like, you know...
Where was I, where am I?
And you gotta remember I got a tube in my mouth,
I got a thing in my throat.
(imitating struggling to talk)
You know, trying to say I'm alive, I'm alive.
And then that nurse in that hospital,
and I never got in touch with her yet.
I hope that somehow she's watching, if you are,
you remember this story, you have to,
'cause I'll never forget it.
She came in the room and I was having a real bad day
and I was getting upset and she said,
let me see what I can do for you.
And she just took this upon herself.
She reached out to my wife, Laurie,
got in touch with Laurie.
And the next thing you know,
she come in the room and she showed me that picture
that you saw on the screen.
And you know, of course you cry.
'Cause...
(choked up) Family.
Yes, I understand. (crying)
It's all you got.
And, I said, that was total motivation,
total motivation and Drew, I can't thank her enough.
I can't thank her enough because
I don't know if I would've made it.
You know, it's easy to quit in life.
Thank God for her.
Have you gotten to speak with her?
No, I have not gotten to speak to her.
That's why I hope in one way or another,
somebody gets this to her and I would love,
love to get together with her one time.
Well, I have someone else here
that I want to surprise you with.
Oh no, no you're not.
I am.
It's actually the doctor that you spoke of,
Dr. Victoria Twito, if you don't mind coming out, please.
Thank you.
(crowd cheers)
How are you?
I'm good, you look amazing.
Thank you.
(inaudible talk)
That's the picture, those are the girls.
Hi.
That's Laurie.
That's Laurie and Michelle.
Sit down, sit down, come on.
I have to catch up with you.
Oh my gosh.
I have to catch up.
Thank you so much.
Laurie, his wife is here
and I can't thank you enough for being here
because hearing Kevin's story-
Neither can I.
Thank you, thank you.
(crowd cheers)
Victoria, you are a doctor.
I am a doctor.
And in that moment, what was it like for your perspective?
Well, I was a brand new doctor.
I was actually still a fourth year medical student,
and then there was an emergency call
to graduate all those fourth year medical students
to increase the number of doctors that could work.
And I had done all my training at that hospital.
And I just figured in a time of mayhem,
this was a good way for me to give back
and take a little bit of control.
And I actually met Kevin after his critical illness
had already passed and I think that when you think of,
you know, the ICUs and the intensity,
obviously that part is very difficult to get through.
But we also forget that
once you've been in a bed for over 40 days,
you got debilitated and there's a lot of work to do
to get back to your normal baseline.
And I just saw that he needed family, I, you know,
family is what you need
to get through these difficult things.
How do you know to do things like that?
Is there a person,
a place, a thing,
something in your life that catapults you
to have that intuitive nature?
I just, that's what I was brought up doing,
was loving people and taking care of people
and treat everyone as if they're your own family.
And that's what I tried to do for you.
Oh, thank God for people like you.
(crowd applauds)
Thank you, Dr. Victoria.
And thank you, Kevin,
for sharing your story
and your family for being here and Dr. Victoria,
I love your story.
Thank you for sharing it with us.
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you.
(crowd cheers)
(upbeat music)